you were talking about Dungeons &
Dragons and it sounds like that's not a
joke you really were into serious really
was from the first we hate I went to Gen
Con anyone here anyone else here meet
Lila Kafka or Gary Gygax I don't think
so
anyway the first aerial battles huh with
a Kirin versus a Pegasus I won that
battle Gygax no one else is I don't know
yeah I uh this room cleared out what you
heard about in high school I never did
the Dungeons & Dragons I didn't really
know I never had a friend no I didn't
ever girl either
oh why I had a little that's a long
story it got better but no I never got
into that but I'm just guessing that if
you were into Dungeons & Dragons you
must have been into Lord of the Rings
yes yes I was I will just say this to
you Conan Ellen Silla lumen moment il
vous or don't you speak Quenya star
shines on the hour of our meeting Conan
yeah yeah okay no I the first I will not
judge you I respect your love of Lord of
the Ring I have been judged on my love
of Lord of the Rings you think you'll
actually get Maddie I got some viewers
on my show get mad at me because
remember to 666 like in June however was
into the world devil day and well CNN
writted a story on it and they ran a
picture of what they you know purported
to be a devil to talk about the devil
day but I happen to know that the
picture they ran of the devil was
actually a painting of a Balrog from the
1977 brothers Hildebrandt
j.r.r tolkien calendar okay yeah so I
called him out on my show I called BS on
him and I explained the difference
between a Balrog and and a demon very
different okay demons are angels who
followed Satan into hell because he
wouldn't serve God balrog z-- our Maya
who followed melkor to thank or add rim
because he wouldn't serve arrow
totally different okay you said that
this got you into trouble yes because
Conan it's an obvious mistake the Balrog
did not follow Melkor to thank origin
they followed him to Oh Tom no and then
later to his fortress of Angad that was
guarded by the three mountains of
Fangoria dream the most humiliating day
of my life and someone called you out he
called me out yeah Wow yeah Wow
incredible on here's incredible I've
actually bred
I've actually mated and had children but
I have sports you know yeah I play nerf
highligh you haven't lived you played
nerve
I'm sorry